please welcome Alan Watts what you
desire what makes you itch what sort of
situation would you like I do this often
in vocational guidance of students they
come to me and say well we're getting
out of college and we haven't the
faintest idea of what we want to do so I
always ask the question what would you
like to do if money were no object how
would you really enjoy spending your
life it's so amazing the results of our
educational system that crowds of
students say well we'd like to be
painters we'd like to be poets we'd like
to be writers I like to live an outdoors
life and ride horses but everybody knows
you can't earn any money that way when
we finally get down to something which
the individual says they really want to
do I will say to them you do that and
forget the money because if you say that
getting the money is the most important
thing you will spend your life
completely wasting your time you'll be
doing things you don't like in order to
go on living that is to go on doing
things that you don't like which is
stupid better to have a short life that
is full of what you like doing than a
long life spent in a miserable way and
after all if you do really like what
you're doing it doesn't matter what it
is you can eventually become a master of
it the only way to become a master of
something is to be really with it and
then you'll be able to get a good fee
for whatever it is therefore it's so
important to consider this question what
do I desire Alan Watts